hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter 3 of John Stuart Mill's
utilitarianism has the title of the
ultimate sanction of the principle of
utility and middle is talking about in
there something we would call these days
a moral principle foundation and he's
keen to try to explain this to us and
part because he's trying to address
criticisms that have been made against
utilitarian philosophy it's not when a
generation in existence by the time he's
writing he's a second generation
yeah a lot of people who have said he
gives this challenge here I feel that
I'm about not to rob or murder betrayer
to see but why am I bound to promote the
general happiness which is the greatest
happiness principle or the principle of
utility what is the ultimate ground for
this why do I have a keyword duty to
promote the general happiness Bentham
have won some of the answers middle is
going to provide some others and they
have to do heart with his conception of
psychology the first we look at st.
themselves his notion of sanctions which
he is deriving in part from so the
general you know culture but also the
part from benefit in Bentham talked
about sanctions in its work she
distinguished for and then later five
different kinds of sanctions mill talks
in terms of external and internal
changes what does he mean by external
and internal internal to the human being
external meaning coming from without in
some way now it could involve the
feelings of the human being their
pleasure or pain as a matter of fact you
can't actually have a sanction on
somebody unless you are affecting them
in some way and so if you talks about
the external sanctions a sense what are
these they are the hope of failure and
fear displeasure from our fellow
creatures as well as from the ruler of
universe along with whatever we may have
sympathy or affection for them where I
love and walk for him inclining us to do
as well independently of selfish
consequences so what would you know if
we take out of the picture because Mill
is not really all that sincere though
about God and they may complicate things
what we're talking about is other
people's approval or disapproval
punishment reward and then whatever
feelings sympathy or affection which we
have for them
so I help an old woman across the street
that's probably promoted to general
happiness unless they don't know yeah so
why am i doing them I could be motivated
by my my parent telling me go ahead and
help her across the street I'll make it
worth your while there'd be an external
sanction that's reward it could be that
I'm worried about what people will think
of me if they see me not helping her out
in the social
this approval that's also an external
sanction it could be that I action biker
or I feel sorry her I feel some sort of
aspect if 'ti moving me towards to
what's helping her that also is in those
an external section so what would be
what you know sort of things that we
could call it in general section people
speak in terms conscience or mostly
online or yeah how can you tell when
somebody is is motivated by internal
sanctions rather than external sanctions
well but nobody's watching so you have
to agree well social disapproval or
approval well there's no punishment or
reward at stake and when they don't have
any particular feelings of sympathy or
infection already moving them towards
that do they do the right thing do they
refrain from robbing and then they
return lost property do they tell the
truth do they avoid telling lies or
deceiving we could go down the list do
they actually do what they should and
what we're really interested in here is
what the internal sanction of Duty would
be and he says it's a feeling in our own
mind a pain more or less intent
attendant upon a violation of duty which
improperly cultivated moral nature Rises
of the more serious cases into shrinking
from it as an impossibility so when
somebody says my conscience won't allow
me to do that way see they have in mind
exactly what Bill was talking about
highly developed person this will
actually keep them from being
to consider it as a possibility for
themselves not necessarily as a
possibility other people by the
possibility of themselves if it hasn't
developed that parts at least a certain
kind of pain and you're lying that says
this is wrong I shouldn't do that or
being faced with a positive Duty
something that you ought to do that you
know thinking about not doing it you
feel a sense of so what is the sanction
what is the basis for utilitarian
morality he asks and no no is engaging
in a bit of psychology and he says where
do we get these notions of are they what
he calls a transcendental fact an
objective reality blurring to the
province of things and themselves
minister note it doesn't actually buy
that he thinks that we exit sort of work
this out so what we want to ask is is
the notion of duty or is it does it
arise intuitively from being and human
being we sort of born with them it's
hardwired into us or isn't something
that we acquired through experience
through association through feeling
pleasure and pain and being the rapid in
certain ways and then coming to see
certain things is good it's a priori or
that sort of language so he said well
let's take the first of all if it is
innate then he says I don't see any
reason why the feeling which is a name
should not be that of regard to the
pleasures and pains of others what you
know is there anything really strange
about saying that people would
intuitively be cognizant and take some
consideration of the pleasures and pains
of other human beings perhaps that's
inherent in human nature not only could
have a person say well what about
sociopaths what about damage some cases
would not be normal
he says if there's any principle of
morals which is intuitively obligatory
that's a big if there's anything that is
intuitively linked Ettore it would be
this principle that we wanted to they
ought not only to pay attention to our
own pleasures remains but those of other
people who are affected by our actions
or choices of living now nipple doesn't
actually think that his remains
but he's covering his bets if one does
think it is and he says if these moral
feelings are not an eight but acquired
they're not for that reason much natural
it is natural to man to speak to reason
to build cities to cultivate the ground
it's also natural to human beings to
cultivate themselves to have rules of
right Ron to have a sense of obligation
of Duty conscience developing so he says
the moral faculty if not a part of our
nature
it's but not something we're like born
with full-blown is a growth front
capable like them like other you know
things in a certain small degree of
springing up spontaneously so some
degree of morality will serves
nature and then the rest of it is is
susceptible of being brought to by
cultivation to a high degree of
development that means that our
environment and our own sort of self
effective choices would play a huge role
in forming the kind of persons that we
are in determining how strong and what
direction this actually takes so from
Mills perspective that you get somebody
who is completely you know consciousness
it could be a product of being in a
terrible terrible environment that gets
all sorts of counterproductive messages
about these sorts of things so he's
talking about moral associations and
whether there's a natural basis of
sentiment for utilitarian morality if it
is implanted we are we going to get this
it's a good question so where where
wouldn't either from he says there is
this basis of powerful natural
sentiments remember this does turn
natural does not mean just simply pour
it in us but it's something that we have
a capacity for that can be developed
powerful natural sentiments and what is
that actual sentence he says the desire
to be in unity with their fellow
creatures so that does make the detail
militaria choices actions those in turn
are going to sort of a cycle here are
going to reinforce this powerful natural
sentiment over time through habits the
force of the paddle through the force of
association and producing us a condition
of sort of naturally thinking about how
our actions our choices are going to
affect other people in terms of their
own pleasures their own pain their own
happiness their own misery
he says the social state is at once so
natural necessary to Mitchell
and that except for someone usual
circumstances are by an effort of allah
terry abstraction he never conceives of
themself otherwise them as a member of
body and this association was riveted
more and more as we are removed from the
state of savage independence so mill is
actually telling a story here where
ridge '''l e we are sort of like the the
Cyclops and in The Odyssey that Greek
political theories pick up on each you
know each man runs his own household
does what he wants gives himself his own
laws and said screw room everybody else
I'm going to do what I want
mill thinks that as we become more
developed as we get away from this state
of total barbarism or savagery we begin
to take more and more heed of other
human beings because we more and more
understand Express fulfill this desire
to be a unity with other human beings
that makes us feel good so we do it's
war
that eventually becomes sort of second
nature to us so he says that's that's a
sort of the basis now how does this
actually take shape
it says society between human beings
except in the relation of Master and
slave so purely tyrannical power
relation accepted in the the relation of
Master it's like is impossible on any
other footing than that the interests of
all are to be consulted so think of a
family for example you have the family
and you're not consulting the interests
of all the only way in which you can do
that as some person imposes the choice
the power from above the other people
below or you said complete
yeah if you're actually going to have a
harmonious family life the person who's
making the decisions in any given case
has to consult the interests of
everybody else they have to treat them
not necessarily every single person
who's equals but everybody has to treat
as he said somebody is evil
he says society between equals can only
exist on the understanding that the
interests of all are to be regarded
equally we're supposed to take account
of everyone's interests he says in every
age some advance is made towards a state
in which it will be impossible to live
permanently on other terms with anybody
so we're moving from a state originally
where only power can really take to take
place to conditions of equality where a
sort of limited utilitarian morality
becomes way in which we do things
without necessarily calling it
utilitarianism without necessarily
thinking about it in those sort of terms
we begin to consult everybody else's
interests and then as time goes on we
become more more developed in that
respect and eventually we reach the
point where any decision that anybody
thinks is already thinking about how
everybody else is going to be affected
now
Mills sees that as quite far off he
doesn't think that's going to happen now
you might say at this point that doesn't
sound like our social life at all are
you saying John Stuart Mill that our
experience of social life is that we're
we're all motivated by this intense
natural desire to be in unity with our
fellow humans why are people such jerks
to each other then why are we in
competition and middle parks quite a bit
about experiences and cooperating with
others what the
does but then he ends up saying that if
we're in an early stage of development
so a lot of this is kind of far along he
says that we really looked at our real
interests not just our imaginary
interest not just what you know we're
getting from imperfect understandings of
the social order or from propaganda or
poorer
you know poorer environments that give
us bad experiences which we draw the
wrong conclusions from if we can get
away from all of that that will see that
really we ought to be cooperative with
each other
yeah he ends up saying this is where
I'll actually end this thing even if you
don't buy this it would be in your
interests given a society where a lot of
people are seeing things in the
utilitarian way to act like a
utilitarian to take on the
characteristics of that and if you do
that enough become that habit will
become your new character become your
new structure of desires and it's also
in your interest to see other people
behave like that
because think about if you want a purely
egoistic environment no because you
don't want everybody else to be egoist
you don't want that to privilege their
mitres contains over yours you want them
to take yours into account and one of
the ways to make sure that they're going
to do that is by sort of pushing this
utilitarian
morality on other people and one way you
can do that was by actually you know
espousing it yourself and acting like a
utilitarian so even if you he says even
if you don't buy it even if you have no
interest and sympathy you know
pleasures and pains of others you're
greatly interested as anyone that others
should have it so mill thinks that all
these things come together and provide
us with the sense of duty that we have
that ultimately rests on this sort of
complex and this is the fundamental
basis for this desire which comes from
our nature but to be developed further
further to be in unity with fellow
humans